If you ever heard of this company for probiotics floor.com, I heard about it from Dr. V. Just wondering if the science was legit and it's worth it says trying to heal my God.
No, I have not heard of that. I know there's a, I don't know. I didn't even look at this before looking at this question.
I, I, is this the company that, you know, they do a fecal test and measure your, your, your, your flora and then give you a customized probiotic for that.
Now that sounds really exciting with that those kind of maybe it's not, but with those labs started coming out. I thought they were really cool. It sounds really exciting, but you really do the research.
I'm trying to, you know, create a healthier microbiota by simply giving a probiotic capsule and it's pretty poor. You really can't make major changes in your microbiota simply by taking a probiotic capsule really has to be through your diet.
The changes in your microbiota, it gets, it gets even more complicated literally change your microbiota changes the study showed that your microbiota changes daily your microbiota changes daily by the people you come in contact with.
It changes daily by the foods that you ate that day.
And I've seen studies where they've done got microbiota tests on people every week and it literally changes every week in this person. They had no treatment. They were not doing anything. Nothing was changing their microbiota change.
Drast can change drastically and then they did in the study they did.
They measured you know what the people were doing different they just had to do with oh well we had we got apples this week and we ate apples already did this this week and we ate this.
Your microbiota is very fluid and it changes a lot your diet is the thing that changes it and people that you come in contact with your touching in the areas that you're going changes that people have very different microbiota.
There is no norm really parent people have very different microbiota pen and where they live or diet that they eat the culture that they're in the motor human contact that they have.
And that's why people transplants can be so helpful for people people that have ulcerative colitis that I'm just really damaged microbiota.
The best way to give them a basically a new microbiota as do a vehicle transplant that's basically an animal that's a retention animal with somebody else's feces.
So yeah I know this company might be something totally different but so I guess I don't know anything about this company so.